the liquor light of the sponsors of this
next segment are giving us a cocktail to
be thankful for here's what's on their
menu for the Thanksgiving holiday
Welcome to our shop I'm Solomon Nick
what's the liquor lineup for today so
today we are having a Sloe Gin Fizz this
is going to be a perfect cocktail for
your next Thanksgiving get-together or
friendsgiving so let's get started so
first we're going to do a three-fourths
an ounce of Ford's gin
next up we have three-fourths an ounce
of Ford's Sloe Gin now this you can't
find everywhere this is a limited time
offering it's an Ultra Premium slow gin
from Fords what's fantastic is we have
it in our shops and also you can
download our app liquor lineup and we
can deliver it to your door we do
delivery daily at liquor lineup all
right so I just added some fresh lime
lemon juice and a little bit of simple
syrup we're gonna go ahead and shake
that up
all right we're going to strain it over
ice and then we're gonna top this with
some really awesome premium Q mixers
club soda
alrighty and let me hand this off to you
uh let me know what you think fantastic
I'm excited
Nick that's phenomenal awesome great to
hear Happy Thanksgiving
all right we want to thank liquor lineup
for sponsoring this segment if you'd
like more information scan that QR code
right there on the screen give you a few
seconds get it it's on our website too
we'll be right back
[Music]